it's date night we're having a good time
[Applause]
from Perry Underwood and Mike Fisher to
Miranda Lambert with Brendan mobile
Flynn CMAs ladies we're all about PDA
and paying tribute to Legends lost from
Loretta Lynn
Loretta is unquantifiable I mean what
she did for our genre she's one of one
yeah she's incredible incredible to
Naomi Judd in death there is life and
here I am I'm just an example of life
after death you just show up and you
have showed up in so many ways you are
on tour
[Music]
we've recreated 1991 the show that Mom
and I did our final show how is it
reliving it's painful as hell it's
beyond anything I could ever understand
and I'll never understand it so I just
have to walk through it it's walk with
it hold your head up high and don't be
afraid of the storm walk on
have You Met My New Country Queen right
here this is this is two out of three
yeah in four different denim looks
elevated and elegant and our cowgirl hat
Katy Perry made her CMA Awards debut
singing her duet with Thomas Rhett and
last night's co-host Luke Bryan wasn't
gonna remain Idol my feelings you know
my feelings were hurt she just chose a
younger version I get it she's she's
staying and staying in her age bracket
he's stressed he's going over his Lines
no we are going to now mess up Luke's
entire performance tonight you and
Caroline should okay I'm gonna get her
on the tequila train time
the Nashville night had no shortage of
electric performances you're fine
but everyone's talking about this Triple
Threat Kelly Clarkson Kelsey ballerini
and Carly Pierce
Kelsey's my closest friend in this
industry he's gonna get to flip it and
be us on the stage is really fun and
Kelly is the nicest person ever and so
down to earth and we've just clicked
really fast it's giving blue is the
moment
as for Kelsey's blue Balenciaga look she
accidentally had a red carpet twin
Mackenzie Porter I immediately changed
into a green dress because she looked so
good in it don't you dare do it who wear
it better and if the dress looks
familiar that's because Kim Kardashian
rocked it earlier this year's
also in the building Kelsey's ex-husband
Morgan Evans the two filed for divorce
in August talk to me about some of your
new music so over for you you wrote this
during a very difficult vulnerable time
in your life it was a really rough time
and and writing this song like helped
sort through a lot of it and sharing it
was as you say a very vulnerable but it
was cathartic at the same time I want to
thank my beautiful beautiful wife Nicole
our beautiful four and a half month old
son Texas at home right now
Luke Combs to come the biggest Award of
the night Entertainer of the Year it was
parents night out for him and his wife
Nicole but by Lainey Wilson's side cause
I just don't do it this is my daddy
Brian he actually had a lot of um health
issues this year and he's not supposed
to be here and he's here and that's a
win in itself so
um that's a celebration we're
celebrating a lot but most importantly
that
awesome and two major wins Laney took
home both new artists and female
vocalists of the Year this right here is
for for everybody who has believed in me
and a little bit for the ones who even
didn't no one has done this since 2006.
Carrie Underwood took home wow new
artists and female vocalists of the year
you're following in her foot that's
crazy so that's insane yeah that is the
best night of my life I'll tell you that
thank you
foreign